résume prêts à faire le même reportage
aller dans les banlieues et voir des
trucs sur ses vraies causes il a raison
ça serait bien mais association qui est
plein de jeunes parce que moi aussi j'ai
grandi dans sa serait bien ça moi j'ai
grandi à moins de 1300 euros il ya des
choses seraient bien qu'ici pas encore
là et j'ai pas basculer vers le
rassemblement national et est-ce que
vous êtes prêts à aller avec une caméra
voir les gens ici rex à seignosse impose
aucun problème je finis ma chérie
je vais là-bas non c'est ce que vous
êtes prêts à aller à la fac de
saint-denis où voir où la fac de
saint-denis regorge de jeunes de
quartiers mais avec des masters qui ont
des licences qui ont des doctorats
qu'ils trouvent pas de travail justement
et qui finissent gardien de guardian qui
sont contraints de partir à l'étranger
voilà alors
d'accord avec moi mais je crois que vous
êtes d'accord que quand vous allez dans
des endroits et que vous faites
l'apologie du mal parce que sur l'un des
vendeurs de drogue
après on va pas rentrer dans le débat
d'où vient la drogue ils n'ont pas donné
plus taire les vendeurs de drogue dont
on voit pas rentrer dans ce truc là mais
ça c'est 3% mais 97 % qui galère des
éducateurs à qui on a coupé lozère est
ce que on veut plus les aider les jeunes
qui sont dans des dans des classes nyha
65 élèves ou le prend il est prêt à y
aller il est prêt à y aller mais moi je
veux bien y aller mais en fait quand
vous êtes là la guillotière les gens il
vous parle pas des assauts qui fonde
avec vous
je pense que les gens qui sont au
pouvoir ont aussi le bleu moi je parle
de la mission de régler les problèmes
oui il ya des choses qui très bien
qu'ils se font en banlieue 93 un des
premiers départements en france qui va
vous aider qui créent des boîtes
jean-luc problème c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de la ba de gens qui peuvent
pas monter une entreprise parce que
quand il monte une entreprise il ya des
problèmes de sécurité et que est bon
mais c'est bien ça sera les médecins
partent à votre nom mais pourquoi les
médecins partent de dudu 80 points il ya
des déserts médicaux puis seulement dans
les campagnes et maintenant le 93 la
passe qu'il soit ils sont attaqués parce
que leur voiture se fait casser et sa
célèbre agence et les honnêtes gens qui
triment nancy dans les hôpitaux faute
dans le déni vous êtes dans le déni mais
non mais j'ai pas médecin mais c'est
intéressant ce qu'ils disaient bouder
parce que c'est vrai que vous pourriez
aller dans des quartiers où ça se passe
bien mais
c'est un voyage long de l'année mais
jordan hill pour faire une émission pas
avec vos remarques à quelqu'un d'autre
on
voit que le côté négatif ah oui c'est
vrai mais tu as raison brière j'étais
éducateur pendant dix ans dans les
quartiers avant d'être comique puisque
j'étais comptable personne m'a donné
travail alors je suis parti dans
éducateurs et éducateurs auprès des
jeunes et le problème c'est le travail
c'est alors qu'ils ont fait des études
ils ont fait plein de choses mais ces
gens là on n'en parle pas on préfère
parler de 2,3 mais qui sont complètement
est clair qu'ils ont choisi cette vie
parce qu'eux aussi ils ont eu des
problèmes dans leur vie non on parle pas
des 97 personnes et e.on des doctorats
je peux présenter cent mille personnes à
saint denis qui ont des doctorats et qui
trouvent pas de travail et qui font la
sécu à franprix met donc ils ont la
sécurité ces gens là aussi mais je parle
pas de ça je vous le dis pourquoi vous
mettez pas en avant ces gens là un non
mais enfin je me suis bien je me refais
une émission assez mais j'habitais juste
à côté problème
quand on va là-bas c'est plutôt de
sécurité dont on entend par dont parlait
jamais ok je pense qu'il avait juste
m'attends d'ailleurs